all right again it is time for drew's
news your daily grading of the fresh
news
parmigiano and with me at the desk is my
best co-pilot ever ross
[Applause]
all right first up in the news we're all
guilty of a little impulse purchase now
and then and the cut reports that
nicholas cage just revealed one of his
it's a two-headed snake and he bought it
for eighty thousand dollars
he said he had a dream about it two had
an eagle and then the next day he heard
that the two-headed snake was for sale
and he was like obviously so
unfortunately it turns out
the two heads did not get along
he tried putting a spatula in between
them at feedings but he said it just got
too freaky and if it's too freaky for
nicholas cage it's gonna be freaky yeah
but he safely returned them to a zoo you
know that when they we tell kids they
went to that farm yeah yeah living in
there yeah well that's where these
snakes went uh ross thought i mean oh
this is something only nicholas cage
would do right a two-headed snake but
the freakiest part of the story is that
the heads didn't get along i know right
can you imagine you're a two-headed
snake for starters you're like man and
then the worst part is like you don't
like each other
what are you coming over here to be like
why come here you guys where are you
coming are you doing two headed tonight
you would not need any spatula between
us
maybe we are a two-headed snake right
can you imagine if you didn't like your
other head it was just some jerk snake
who ate like tuna salad and its breath
always smelled right next to your face
um wow have you ever done something like
that like bought something impulsively
and regretted it
oh my god haven't we all yeah it may not
have been a two-headed snake it was not
a two-headed snake like i'll buy like an
old flea market scandinavian table
because it folds up into a console this
big but then it expands out to like a
amazing 12-person dinner table and like
i'm like one day i'm gonna make this
table yeah those are my impulses you're
gonna make it my impulse purchase is a
sweater with horizontal stripes i always
think i can pull that off and then i get
it home and i'm like i can't pull that
off
the hamburglar night total hamburglar
that's what i look like in horizontal
stripes you'll never look good all right
well next we've got a new trend in
makeup and do i want your take on this
uh for a while you know it's it's been
all about keeping it minimal with a very
no makeup kind of look but now nylon
reports it's all about party girl
aesthetic and it's happening in beauty
and in fashion and it's described as a
look that's sort of messy at times but
real which also describes this show okay
um oh my god it really does right we are
messy but real we keep it real but it
gets a little messy around here and uh
and but in in this turn they're talking
about popping some sparkly eye makeup
but also pairing it with a messy bun or
a ponytail are you into this look
i love it you do
i do because what i started this company
flower beauty 10 years ago and we it was
like the birth of instagram and then it
was like the heavy contour
kind of all the tips and tricks we could
teach each other
over
social media
um it became a lot about artistry really
and i think you know drag race had a lot
to do with stuff like that yeah we got
into the theatrics and then all of a
sudden for the last few years it's super
fresh face pandemic we you know
everything comes full circle and now
this sort of like sexy smokey leftover
party girl thing euphoria inspired
something youthful it's a little i just
i'm into it well i think that all sort
of it's because of what we've been
through for the past couple years we've
all been at home in our uh like elastic
clothing right watching makeup tutorials
with our hair on a bun and now they open
the doors out and we're like well this
is the new look this is
this is now fashion and get into it
that's exactly right it's a little bit
of a hybrid it's a little 90s i'm into
it
[Music]